All right, you're done.
Let's take a look at the solution.
Just like in our content provider test,
we can use get content resolver to
query based upon the content URI.
Remember, that the default
location entry content URI
just passes all of the parameters
into the database.
So, we can easily construct a query
containing the location query
to see if it is in the database yet.
Remember that the default
location entry content URI
passes all of the parameters into
the database, so we can easily construct
a query containing the location setting
to see if it is in the database yet.
If it's not,
then the query will return an empty set.
And we should insert the new city name,
location setting, and
coordinates together.
Note that we're calling that ad location
method, from inside doing background.
Which calls getWeatherDataFromJson.
We've uncommented out the test
ad location function.
Now, we'll run our tests,
and our tests all pass.
We're ready to move on to the next step.